[Music]
hey and welcome since the ben shapiro
show big hour plan for you a little bit
later on in the l we're going to be
having on the only pollster who even
remotely
got it right robert kahale we're going
to be having him on to take his victory
lap has well deserved a victory lap plus
a victory lap from representative chip
roy who defeated wendy davis
who's a terrible person in texas we'll
get to all that a little bit later on in
the hour first
your updates because this race is not
yet over cnn
fox news they've both both called
michigan for joe biden at this point
they've also both called wisconsin for
joe biden at this point that means
that if that is accurate and trump is
challenging in wisconsin he is
challenging in michigan they have filed
lawsuits in wisconsin
they are suggesting that there may be
voter irregularities in wisconsin at the
very least there will be a recount
in michigan they are suggesting that the
voting ought to be stopped until
there can be a better way of getting
poll watchers in there because
apparently there's some polling stations
where lawyers for trump have actually
been expelled from the premises at least
those are the reports that we are seeing
online
but assuming that both michigan and
wisconsin did in fact go to joe biden by
extraordinarily
narrow margins that leaves one possible
opening
for trump maybe two okay the possible
openings for trump
he needs obviously to win pennsylvania
and then if he wins pennsylvania he
needs to take arizona
or nevada if you were to take
pennsylvania and nevada
then we get the uh then we get the
apocalyptic scenario of 269 versus 269
right then you actually get an electoral
college
heat and this thing gets decided by the
house of representatives
nevada is accelerating its release of
voting details
so nevada i don't know what they're
doing over in nevada honestly honest to
god i do not understand what they are
doing over in nevada so they paused the
voting account
and then they were like you know what
we'll give you all the votes on thursday
now
they're saying oh yeah you know what now
that you guys are also curious about
this i guess we'll accelerate we'll give
it to you later today
um what now wait what yeah
you didn't think that in an election
year we might want to know the results
fast like
you're just going to take your time out
you have to go to the strip club like
what's going over
in nevada what's happening in nevada you
had to go to the magic show i'm i'm very
confused
okay we'll have nevada results a little
bit later on we're also going to get
final results from arizona tonight okay
so the trump campaign i've been speaking
with folks over the trump campaign
and they are expressing a lot of
optimism about both arizona and
pennsylvania in fact
they said it is not just it is not just
possible
they are suggesting it is likely that
trump can still win arizona and
pennsylvania here are the statistics
that you need to know via team trump in
arizona
joe biden currently leads by
approximately 93 500 votes
there were 605 000 votes cast on
election day
in order for trump to make up that 93
500 vote deficit
he would need to pull 57.73 of those 605
000 votes
team trump says they are currently
outdoing those numbers
they say they're pulling 62 percent in
maricopa county which is phoenix and the
phoenix suburbs
and 72 to 80 percent in the other
counties that means the team trump is
projecting anywhere from a 30 000 to a
000 vote win in arizona
they are also projecting that in
pennsylvania trump will win
trump himself has already said he he is
claiming the state which is not of
course how this works you don't get to
declare that you want to state it's not
like michael scott declaring bankruptcy
nonetheless bill stephen has suggested
that team trump has won pennsylvania the
reason he is saying that is because
they're looking
at the stats and here's what they see
trump is up by approximately 454
000 votes are 1.12 million votes
outstanding in pennsylvania
biden requires 78 of those votes to make
up the nearly 500
000 vote difference now 300 000 those
votes in philadelphia right so that
narrows the gap significantly because
philly
is a biden town even if biden were to
win 95
of those votes however he still would
need to pull 70 percent of the other
votes which is a heavy lift
so team trump is expressing a fair bit
of they say that by friday
it's going to be clear that trump is
still the president they say that by
friday when all the votes are counted in
pennsylvania when all the votes are
counted in arizona
fox news ap are going to be put on the
hook and they're going to have to
reverse themselves on arizona
meanwhile we are seeing all sorts of uh
confusion
in michigan people are
gathering outside the polling places
in michigan and outside the vote
counting areas in michigan
and the media are covering it as those
mob is at hand now i do love how the
media will call it a mob when people
literally stand around
outside a balloting place
you know when mobs actually burn things
down then they're like whatever that's
not a mob that's just a peaceful protest
looks like a mostly peaceful protest to
me to be honest with you
nonetheless right now this thing is
still very much up in the air and
anybody who claims that it is not up in
the air
is trying to sell you something at this
point we're gonna know
the outcome of the election in all
likelihood by friday one way or another
and we'll probably have a pretty good
idea of where things stand when all the
arizona votes come in
this evening apparently there are two
tranches of votes that are supposed to
come in
one happens at 9 30 pm pacific time and
the other happens apparently
just after midnight pacific time so
we'll have a very good idea at that
point what's going on
president trump tweeted out earlier we
have claimed for electoral vote purposes
the commonwealth of pennsylvania
which won't allow legal observers the
state of georgia and the state of north
carolina each one of which has a big
trump lead
additionally we hereby claim the state
of michigan
if in fact there was a large number of
secretly dumped ballots as has been
widely reported
okay well you can't claim mission i mean
that's not how that works
are you going to file a lawsuit or you
can dispute the election but uh you
don't just get to claim
states willy-nilly it's not like hungry
hungry hippos out here
now he may very well be right it may be
that he wins michigan it may be that the
vote count there is not complete it may
be that
all of the people who are calling it are
doing so preemptively or that they're
voter irregularities
we're going to find out rudy giuliani
that oppressor in philadelphia the
president's personal lawyer
did oppressor in philadelphia claiming
that
a national lawsuit is in the offing to
stop
what he believes is voter fraud or at
the very least voter irregularities in
all of these toss-up states here was
rudy giuliani the president's lawyer
just a few moments ago we are going to
continue the lawsuit here we're going to
bring a second one and then we're going
to bring a federal lawsuit and we're
going to take a very good look at
whether
we bring this nationally we certainly
are going to bring it here and in
wisconsin
quite possibly we'll do a national
lawsuit and really expose the corruption
of the democrat party but this is beyond
anything i've ever seen
before this comes when you think you
have so much power
and you own the media that you can do
anything you want
okay well they're gonna have to
substantiate those accusations obviously
if this thing goes to court right now
because fox news has already called
michigan
and wisconsin and arizona that puts joe
biden six electoral votes away in the
fox news
count from being president of the united
states presumably if nevada comes in for
biden fox becomes the first network to
call the election
for joe biden which i'm sure do them
wonders with
the fox news audience considering how
early they called arizona whether or not
that's right
a little bit of caution might have been
in the offing but we'll see we'll see
it's weird that we live in a media
environment in which being first is
much preferred to being cautious it
seems like the opposite should be the
case
given how often people have gotten
things wrong in the recent past okay so
the the the race continues to pace joe
biden did a presser today he then called
the lid
he called two lids he called one early
this morning then he called one later
he's just gonna be lids all the way down
so here is joe biden claiming that he is
going to be the next president of the
united states which of course again it
means nothing until the counts are
actually completed
now after a long night of counting
it's clear enough states
to reach 270 electoral votes
i'm not here to declare that we've won
but i am here to report when the count
is finished
we believe we will be the winners okay
so
a little bit of cautious wording there
from joe biden basically saying
i'm not saying we won but i'm pretty
sure we won right then
joe biden went off on the popular vote
which of course nobody cares about
because that is not how the game is
played
if this were about the popular vote then
what you would assume is that president
trump
would worry deeply about going to deep
red states and making sure that
everybody got out to vote
in say tennessee right if this were all
just about the popular vote then what
you would end up with is joe biden
campaigning solely in california and new
york and massachusetts
and donald trump campaigning all over
the deepest red states he'd be in
alabama all day long making sure that
every last person in alabama went out
and voted that's not how this works
here's joe biden talking about the
popular vote even though nobody cares
and it is completely irrelevant
every indication is that the majority
will grow
we have a popular vote lead of nearly 3
million votes
and every indication is that will grow
as well
indeed senator harris and i are on track
to win more votes than any ticket in the
history of this country
that ever won the presidency and vice
presidency
over 70 million votes people say this
sort of stuff that's because the
electorate expanded
okay he didn't win the greatest vote
share in the history of the country he
won 50.3 percent of the vote by current
count
donald trump won 48.1 percent of the
vote that is not a massive victory by
any stretch of the imagination for joe
biden even in the popular vote that dude
was expected to win
by seven percentage points instead
if he does win he's gonna end up winning
by two
okay that is that is nowhere near the
kind of margin he was supposed to win by
he ran a lackluster garbage campaign
he's a lackluster garbage candidate
everybody knows it
the only reason he won if he indeed ends
up winning is because the media put
their thumb
and their elbow and their entire body
weight on the scale against donald trump
and he was able to run
head long away from any difficult
questions the entirety of the campaign
if donald trump ends up not being the
president of the united states the
number one factor
in him not being president of the united
states will have been the media which
militarized to their fullest extent
on behalf of joe biden that is a simple
truth
now the only good news is if joe biden
is president he is going to be a a
much hampered feeble president
right now it appears pretty confident
that the republicans are going to
maintain their senate majority which
means he's not going to be dealing with
a client chuck schumer pushing to get
rid of the filibuster he's instead
going to be dealing with cocaine mitch
and good luck to joe biden on that one
that's good news for americans really
good news for americans having the
backstop
of mitch mcconnell and a republican
senate is extremely
important because joe biden with all of
the controls of the government levers
would be a hell of a lot more scary
than feeble old joe going up against
cocaine mitch one of the great political
operators that i've ever seen
so that's worst case scenario but this
thing ain't over yet
it is not over yet even though everybody
is trying to declare it
over yet my favorite part of this is
that joe biden then declared the
presidency is not a partisan institution
yeah we're going to get
bipartisan joe after campaigning on
wokeness and how half of americans are
terrible awful no good very bad people
now he's going to be the president for
all americans yeah good luck with that
joe
to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents
as enemies we are not enemies
what brings us together as americans is
so much stronger
than anything that can tear us apart so
let me be clear
i we are campaigning as a democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
the president the presidency itself is
not
a partisan institution he was only vp
under the most viciously partisan
president
of my lifetime yes that is true barack
obama was more of a vicious partisan
than donald trump donald trump actually
signed into law
bills with bipartisan support and none
of those were really negotiated or
signed by barack obama
okay so spare me the uh the history onyx
about how joe biden is a great unifier
he is not
so no matter what happens with the biden
trump
race and it appears according to the fox
news analyst that
biden has the upper hand at this point
they are basically one state away from
declaring the election for biden if
nevada comes in for biden they declare
that biden is the president
the trump campaign keeps suggesting that
arizona is still on the table and
pennsylvania
is going to be a win for them we'll see
how all of that shakes out obviously
regardless of what happens on the
presidential level this is a
wild outperformance by republicans
they're going to pick up somewhere from
7 to 12 seats in the house
they're going to maintain the senate
susan collins wins in maine tom tillis
wins in north carolina joni ernst wins
in iowa steve daines wins in montana
republicans maintain
both seats in georgia in all likelihood
that means that joe biden would be face
down with mitch mcconnell and a senate
majority led by republicans
not only that donald trump has opened
some doors here some open
even if he ends up losing he has opened
some doors to future republicans
according to exit polls from edison this
is
last night according to matt brunig who
is a socialist
actually from people policy project he
tweeted out
support for trump by race and gender
trump lost
five points among white men he picked up
two points among white women
54 percent of white women voted for him
he got 17
black male vote okay that's a four
percent uptick from last year
from last time around he got eight
percent of black female vote
35 of the male latino vote and 28
of the latino female vote plus 36
percent of others
i mean those are amazing crosstabs but
that shows that donald trump by the exit
polls
has actually outperformed any republican
since 1960
in terms of the minority vote that is
astonishing
astonishing and they're supporting data
to back this up
according to the new york times their
exit polls showed that donald trump
won the black vote
he won 12 of the black vote okay that is
an improvement
on his performance from 2016
by race donald trump won only eight
percent of the black vote last time
this time at 12 percent by race
donald trump last time won 29 of the
hispanic vote this time
he won 32 percent of the hispanic vote
by race last time he won 29 percent of
the asian vote this time at 31
of the asian vote and for others he won
37 percent last time and 40
at this time this is according to the
new york times okay those are excellent
numbers
for the president like much better
numbers for the president in minority
communities
now he did drop his margin of victory
among people who are 65 and older won 53
of the vote last time on 65 and over
this time among 65 and over 151 percent
but the reality is that while everybody
in the media keeps saying it was white
people who put trump over the top
precisely the opposite
trump actually underperformed his
performance last time with white people
and did better with minorities
he particularly did heavy work among
latinos in florida if you look at the
republican coalition in florida
that looks like the future of the
republican party 55 percent of cubans
voted for donald trump 30 of puerto
ricans
voted for donald trump
a huge percentage of venezuelans voted
for donald trump
and the reason for that is i think
twofold one well threefold one
trump actually took the timeline and
campaigned while the media was mocking
his
poor donald trump dance and music videos
people were actually watching that stuff
two democrats kept saying that they were
warm towards socialism you know it
doesn't like socialism anybody who's
lived under it
people who lived in venezuela or cuba
turns out they're not real fond of
socialism
okay so that was factor number two and
factor number three
is that florida just happens to be a
rudder state
a lot of the people who are who are left
behind by the democrats
democrats who proclaim black lives
matter and sort of left latinos behind
that has real impact see democrats
believe that if they just pander to each
racial group
everything is fine if you just say
amnesty to a person of latino extraction
that means they're going to vote
democrat
or if you just say blm to black people
they're gonna vote democrat
but this election shows that is not the
case you gotta go you gotta do the heavy
lifting you gotta go and you gotta
campaign and trump did that and he
changed the math in florida
fairly dramatically that is a much more
durable and interesting coalition than
the historic republican coalition
there's a lot of talk in the aftermath
of 2012 after mitt romney lost about
making the party more diverse who the
hell knew that it would be donald trump
who did that i think one of the reasons
for that by the way is because donald
trump has a very durable public image
and we've talked about the fact that
everybody has an opinion on trump well
that has its downsides
it also has his upsides meaning that if
you're a latino person
and you've been watching trump for 30
years and watching him on tv and
suddenly they declare that he's a racist
who hates latinos you're like well
really i've been watching him for a long
time
same thing with a lot of black americans
donald trump is used in rap music from
the 90s as like the epitome of being
rich and suddenly you're turning him
into a vicious racist just because he's
a republican
i'm not sure it washed so the woke
narrative
went down to flaming defeat last night
and that is a very very good thing so a
lot of good things happened last night
even as we await the final outcome
of the presidential election we are
joined on the line by robert kahaly his
chief pollster at the trafalgar group
of course gained media attention in 2016
for being one of the pollsters
to accurately predict the election of
donald j trump was much derided by the
chicken entrail reading other pollsters
in the business this year when he
proclaimed that donald trump
was leading in states ranging from
michigan to pennsylvania
well now it seems like he's the only
person who even remotely got it right
robert welcome back to the program for
well deserved victory lap
hey uh it is great to be here and uh
as as complicated as today is it it's
been gratifying for us to see all this
uh to get all this attention well let's
talk about
again what you guys did right and what
everybody else did wrong so there's new
polls showing that a huge percentage of
trump voters
say that they just lied to pollsters or
at least they said that they were not
willing to answer questions
from pollsters you identified a trump
vote that the media suggested did not
exist
honestly i was taken aback by how badly
the polls did considering
they were supposed to fix this thing i
mean that's the part that's so
astonishing to me you know as somebody
who's a fan of data
i have a certain level of faith that if
somebody really really screws up the
next time around they try to do a little
bit better but they did worse this time
than they did the last time
in terms of pulling a lot of these races
that was particularly true in florida
where they screwed it up in 2018 this
time
the real club politics poll average had
joe biden up somewhere between one and
two points he ended up losing it by
three you had
donald trump winning the state by two
points uh the the real
politics polling average suggested that
wisconsin was a blowout in favor of
joe biden you had that thing basically
dead even it was dead even
what did you do right that everybody
else did wrong
well first of all i wasn't shocked at
all because they didn't understand what
they did wrong and they still denied
what they did wrong they don't
understand they cannot accept that the
model
of the certainly the life call is dead
the live call live person people are
going to hide their
feelings especially in the light of
cancer culture and being judged for
their opinion
and so the live interview is dead they
have to get over that they
got to let that sacred cow go but even
worse
michael moore pointed out something that
was very true and that as
trump people tend to be even suspicious
of giving their answer to anybody and so
you have to figure out a way to get
around
all of this and you know
we explain what we did in 2016
with the neighbor question which helped
us but this was a different threshold
because
in 2016 it was just give people
something anonymous and that's good
enough
but this year was a little more because
some of them just didn't want to
participate
at all and they weren't anticipating the
low propensity voters
that were going to turn out you know as
i think i told you before
we isolated what that universe was and
we built them into all of our models
they were being pulled
people whose only vote in the last 20
years was 2016.
uh you know people who fit another set
of
parameters that we put together and then
we had another
new technique that we use that we're not
telling everybody and we're just not
because i
it's really good and there's people who
sign mbas
with punitive damages and who know about
it and it's it's good that's all i can
tell you it's really good
it told me what what not only
who it was but what the real percentage
was
how much hidden vote there was his chief
pollster at trafalgar group and of
course
the pollster who came closest to getting
it right so you suggested in in the last
few polls
he found that trump had advantages in
north carolina which it looks like he's
going to win
and in florida you also suggested he had
advantages in arizona and michigan
michigan has now been called by most of
the networks as
a state for joe biden arizona
has been called by fox news and ap it
has not been called by anybody else the
trump campaign is suggesting that
arizona
is still very much in play what do you
make of that
i mean the dirty secret about how
disorganized
american elections are when you get this
close
is going to come out i mean there there
are things that go on that
probably your your listeners have no
idea about i mean there are
for example do you know that people who
are american expats who live overseas
in many cases are allowed to vote in the
state they last lived in
even if it was 10 years ago and allowed
to vote by email
i know things are happening people
that's right the things people don't
have any idea and so digging into these
things deep
is there's going to be a lot of things
that it it's just
it's not all nefarious it's just a
little more
it's as disorganized as you might assume
something that the government puts on
would be
so let's talk for a second about the
future of the polling industry so
i can say safely that i am one of the
people who is most likely i think
on the right to cite polls and i would
always cite them with a grain of salt
given how wrong they were last time
around
and the fact that they were wrong in
2012 as well but in a different
direction uh
i i pretty much believe that you can
never cite a poll again
uh because this has been such a debacle
and honestly it was it was debacle
not just in the presidential race
particularly in michigan and wisconsin
where things are just nail-bitingly
close
uh but also in the senate races i mean
there was not a single poll not one
that had susan collins winning that race
she's going to run away with that race
there are polls that were showing
that jamie harrison was going to run a
competitive race with lindsey graham and
south carolina blew him out by 13 points
i mean what kind how should americans be
treating polls
in the future is the polling industry
basically dead
well i should certainly hope it's not
dead for all of us
if it's going to be dead for the rest of
us guys that will be fine
um but remember it's always about what
your goal was
so if your goal if your goal was to
reflect the election
it might be dead but if your goal was to
affect the election
then they might be declaring mission
accomplished in a couple of days
so uh looking into what your goal was
yeah so
so you think that there was an actual
nefarious goal by some of these
pollsters
to to rack up points on behalf of the
biden campaign and therefore dissuade
trump voters from even going to the
polls
it seems to be what you're suggesting i
i am suggesting that
if you believe the media has an agenda
how can you possibly believe the media
pollsters don't have an agenda
i mean it i have to have a conversation
with everyone who hires us to do a poll
and and generally the way the
conversation goes if i'm doing this for
you
and you want to release it publicly you
need to understand
if you don't like what it says we won't
release it but i will not cook it for
you
my reputation is not worth that i don't
know that everyone has those
conversations i have reason to believe
they
in fact do not have those conversations
and
you know if you look to the planet
racist we poll we actually predict him
it's how he would lose
we predicted tillis would win and we
also were the only ones who predicted
john james
would win now that one's going to come
down to the wire too and you know
he might not but everybody else said it
was going to be a blowout and we said
he'd win by one point
and again we're going to be closer than
everyone else
so looking at some of the other
pollsters you know not all polls as you
mentioned are created equal
it seems like some of these these polls
should just never be
even looked at remotely again now the
ones that i have in mind are quinnipiac
which had
joe biden up as of like two days ago 11
points
11 points in the national race and was
pulling that way consistently throughout
the race with they had biden up
10 points 11 points throughout the race
how's how are
places like quinnipiac taken seriously
do you think they still get paid by the
media outlets do you think the media
outlets have any interest at all
in having better posters or are they
just perfectly satisfied with throwing
out whatever chum uh allows their their
listenership or readership or viewership
to feel good about themselves
well i mean i you know as much as i'm
as much as i'm a fan of fox news i mean
look at how bad theirs are
and and a lot i mean do you remember how
many times last night the little meter
showed like a
you know uh this huge percent like an 80
chance of like trump
losing north carolina i mean like but
they were basing their election
death calls on some surveys that they
did that were already terrible
so i don't i don't know how a lot of
these guys stay employed i don't
understand it it doesn't make sense
um unless there's a reason
i don't understand how they you know
they failed again in 2018 i mean
they said they fixed it but it wasn't
adjusting for education
it was they weren't identifying the
hidden voters i
watched an interview with frank lutz
talking to bret bear today
and he was talking about well they
missed this they missed this and they
didn't find the trump photos and i know
how
it's like are you having an out-of-body
experience you missed this
you are the one who said that our our
industry
it will go away if we are wrong about
this you were wrong about it too
but yet he's still on fox talking how do
you explain that
so we're speaking with robert k haley's
chief pollster at the trafalgar group
and obviously
they came closest to getting this one
right so moving forward
uh let's assume for the sake of argument
that president trump uh eventually is
declared not the winner of the election
uh and joe biden has declared the winner
uh and he's no longer on the bow do you
think that the social desirability bias
that you've talked so much about and
that has really been
a chief distinguishing feature of your
polling strategy do you think that
remains in the absence of trump or do
you think that that's a trump
specific phenomenon
i think that the social desirability
bias that trump had in 2016
would have evaporated but the social
desirability bias that is now a
reflection
of cancer culture will probably continue
to a certain degree
um especially as people you know
if under abiding if in the scenario
biden were to win
and under a biden administration the
punishment of conservative values the
canceling the
the demonization is allowed to run
rampant then you will see people go
further to ground with their genuine
opinions
well robert haley again i think it will
be baked in
again congratulations on your successful
showing last night you put a lot of
people
who are supposed to be the wisest among
us uh you you really put them behind the
eight ball
uh trafalgar group did an excellent job
uh as they had the last couple of
elections
uh in in forecasting in this election
way nobody else did
uh congratulations and dude i hope that
it results in money for you because
the other pollsters have received an
enormous amount of money for getting
this thing absolutely 100 wrong
i hope that the the big checks come your
way to continue doing what you're doing
well listen uh we we appreciate we
appreciate that it's you know it's been
a
a bittersweet day i mean the country's
going through a lot of drama but we're
getting a lot of accolades so uh
you know take it as it comes but uh it's
an honor to be on the show
and if you need anything you let me know
i appreciate it it's robert k haley
chief polster at trafalgar group
so as we mentioned it is chaos out there
uh you have some people forecasting that
trump
is uh indeed going to win pennsylvania
that is his campaign you have others
who are forecasting that he is going to
lose pennsylvania when all of the votes
are eventually counted and that includes
a variety of mainstream media sources
who are looking at the stats sean trendy
who's been a guest on the program he
also suggests that there is a margin
that uh that could be made up here by
joe biden jonathan tamari
who is a a writer for the philadelphia
enquirer
he says the trump's edge is now down to
about 300 000 in pennsylvania
there's still about 900 000 mail ballots
uncounted as of yet biden has been
winning about 78
of those if that number holds biden
would in fact surpass trump's advantage
in pennsylvania
we're going to find out where all of
this stands in very short nevada is
supposed to announce its statistics
tonight arizona is supposed to announce
its final statistics
tonight trump has an awful lot of ground
to make up but this thing is not over
yet there are going to be lawsuits
there's going to be accusations of voter
fraud and we're going to have to see
where all of it turns out every
legitimately
cast ballot should be counted and no
illegitimately cast ballot should be
counted
all of that should be relatively
uncontroversial at this point
we're joined on the line by congressman
chip roy represented from the 21st
district of texas big winner last night
defeated wendy davis that was a
hotly contested race considering that
that district covers parts of austin
wendy davis again goes down to flaming
defeat every time she runs for office
apparently she goes down to flaming
defeat every time she wants to enter
the federal government and that is
excellent news because uh basically the
only thing she's ever famous for
is abortion on demand congressman roy
congratulations thanks for joining the
show
hey ben i appreciate it uh great to uh
vanquish wendy davis and uh hopefully
she's done running for office we'll see
but it's great to great to
be victorious last night right it's
definitely a good thing so texas
was originally forecast as a state that
might go blue last night once again this
was lucy with the football the democrats
it turns out
had no shot of winning texas trump won
the state by six you defe you defeated
wendy davis by fully seven percent of
the vote
why do democrats keep thinking that
texas is turnable and then why does it
turn out that texas is never turnable
well look i think there's a number of
reasons why and i appreciate the
question uh
you know people think that just because
there's a lot of people who move to
texas they keep hanging their hat on all
these people move there you know texas
all these californians but now we can
flip it
look i run into thousands of people
across texas who are
seeking refuge from california taking
refuge from oregon from
chicago from new york and uh they seek
freedom i see them every day i go to
events go to rallies and i talk about
them
they raise their hand um it's so i think
that's a false notion i also think
what we saw yesterday so many hispanics
voted for the president voted for
republicans
and it proved a point you remember back
in 2012 when after the romney loss
the rnc put out their autopsy saying we
gotta pretty much pander
and you know break out like a mariachi
band or something in order to win
hispanic votes
it's a lie it's not true hispanic voters
want what we want
freedom opportunity they also want
border security they do
border patrol agents hispanics along the
border are tired of cartels endangering
lives both for people here and
immigrants who seek to come here
they want what we want they want the
rule of law and so i think
we should put that to bed and we should
make everybody understand the president
ran on border security
uh i ran on border security it sells and
so
i think we saw that come out in spades
uh last night
it is definitely impressive how
republicans turned out hispanic voters
particularly
in texas and florida where the
statistics show once again that all the
demographics is destiny nonsense that
you hear from both
democrats fairly on a mainstream level
and all writers
it's just it's just crap republicans are
fully capable of winning a heavy share
of the
hispanic vote in fact in the in the
single most hispanic district in america
in texas 96
hispanic district joe biden only won
that district 5247 over donald trump who
according to the media was a vicious
racist who hated
everybody of hispanic heritage and
extraction
it is pretty incredible that despite
four years of the democrats and the
media but i repeat myself calling
republicans vicious racists
republicans on the national level
outperformed their percentage votes with
minorities
by leaps and bounds uh they've done so
much better uh this year than they did
in 2012
for example that it should once and for
all starts to put to bed
a lot of the the kind of woke ideology
that suggests
that there's no way republicans can ever
make inroads into these groups
no look that's 100 right and i hope we
remember that and that we talk about
that we're running for the forgotten men
and women who are working hard every day
for america to work
you know we're out there campaigning for
the people who love their country
who want their communities protected who
stand with the police
this is not complex stuff it's the basic
duty of government
and if we do that people flock to us
look there's a handful of these woke
white liberals
college-educated sitting down in the
suburbs hand-wringing about all this
but look they'll come home and they'll
come home and we go out and we start
talking about keeping our community safe
having a strong economy
treating everybody with respect but the
rule of law matters and that
be honest about it and uh look i think
honestly
if we had been on that message more
robustly rather than on defense on the
virus just a couple of weeks back even
sooner
i think the president would have rolled
through the election it wouldn't be
close now obviously right now we're
hoping arizona comes through
we're hoping the president pulls it
through but it's going to be really
close
i'm you know certainly glad our election
turned out well and i ran in hardcore
liberal austin
i did better in travis county in austin
this cycle than i did
last cycle running on a no-nonsense
conservative agenda
highlighting a wendy davis side against
the police sides of the lm and antifa
and i just took it head on and we won it
seems to me more than anything else this
election was a referendum on wokeness
and cancel culture because
that's really what it was about i mean
the the polls got it wrong because they
assumed
that everybody was talking to a pollster
was speaking honestly and was not afraid
of being cancelled or ostracized and
that just isn't true and democrats never
put forward any sort of policy proposals
it was all you're a bad person if you
vote for a republican you're a bad
person if you vote for donald trump
and you're just as bad a person if you
vote for chip roy and i think the
american people
roundly rejected that notion yesterday
which is why
an election that was supposed to go to
joe biden by seven points
in in the end even if it goes to joe
biden is going to go by an
extraordinarily slim margin and
republicans retain the senate and
republicans pick up seven to 12 seats in
the house
no that's exactly right like ben i can't
make this up there was a time when i was
campaigning a few weeks ago when i would
say look
wendy davis and all of these outside
leftist groups who you know are all for
abortion after 20 weeks or all four blm
and deep over cops all these things
they're saying that i hate veterans
they're saying that i hate old people
they're saying that i hate women because
i voted against these big spending bills
these appropriations bills
then i used to joke in my speeches that
they were one day gonna say i hate
puppies
and then i'm not making this up two
weeks ago they put out mailers
saying i hate puppies like this is what
they do
i mean it's it's literally it's it's
like a walking
just joke it's like a snl skit yeah and
um at the end of the day the american
people see through that well that is
definitely true representative roy
we are up on the end of the year
congratulations on your victory and
we're all crossing our fingers for
arizona and pennsylvania for the
president so that republicans can have a
clean excellent night reversal roy
appreciate
the time you're listening to the bench
bureau we'll be back tomorrow with all
of your updates